[Music]
back now with more answers to your
questions our panel of experts comes
back doctors mark Segal Nicole sapphire
and Amy Compton Phillips
all right let's pop the first one on the
screen Deb M asks I am a dental
hygienist and a group practice what
should we be doing to protect ourselves
and our clients
dr. sapphire now this is a great
question and I had to deal with this
myself as to what are we gonna do with
our already scheduled patients and the
truth is we probably shouldn't be doing
routine dental cleanings right now that
it that really involves a lot of close
contact face to face and we're really
trying to avoid that so my first thing
is you should be cancelling all routine
dental appointments now if it's an
emergency case at that point we need to
you should absolutely screen them for
any illness if there is illness they're
gonna happen you're gonna have to be
wearing an n95 mask at the bottom line
is I have a hard time I don't think you
should be doing much of what you do
right now the practice should probably
just assess for emergencies only and
take it on a case-by-case basis got it
will scoot now next question Braden C
asks is this really a threat or is the
media overreacting dr. Compton Phillips
I can tell you unequivocally it's really
a threat because of the curves that you
showed earlier that the doubling rate
you know it doesn't seem like a big deal
when a new infection affects to patients
and for patients and eight patients but
when you go from from 40,000 to 80,000
to 160,000 to 320,000 like this that's a
huge impact and if in in wuhan when the
health care system was overwhelmed
mortality rate of people who came in was
4% so four and a hundred died in other
provinces when the health care system
could keep up with the bad infections it
was 0.7 percent so significantly more
people died if you if it rolls out fast
oh that's it rolls out slow yeah and
you've seen this firsthand you're
leading 51 hospitals one of them treated
the very first patient here in the
United States real quick last thought on
that we are absolutely seeing this now
we are rapidly scrambling and
pairing for the number of ICU beds and
ventilators that we're going to need we
know we'll need within the next few days
because the the virus before the social
distancing took place the virus had
already spread in our market and so we
know we're gonna we're going to continue
to see increasing numbers for the next
couple weeks even though we've shut the
city down well and you've shown us
you're on the other coast what it looks
like when you start to have force
lockdowns dr. Siegel I kind of wanted to
part this question now and thanks to our
viewer for getting it started are we at
a point where we need a national
quarantine or you know we're doing
everything else I don't know if you can
lock people down like they did in Italy
we're a little bit bigger than Italy
we're not quite there yet but the thing
that's in concerning me and also
concerning dr. Falchi who's talked about
this is the disparity between people
like you and me who are sitting social
distancing using hand sanitizers
swabbing down the deck and are people
who are out at bars drinking and acting
like nothing's going on in denial almost
like Nero playing you know when Rome is
burning we got it we've got to figure
out a way to get a consistency of
behavior here or we're gonna have to
superimpose something more stringent we
need to staunch the virus now we should
have been at it weeks ago but we we have
to test we're gonna test many many more
people now we're going to see many many
more cases we have to get control of it
we have to isolate sick people and
everyone in the country has to follow
these guidelines and it together Team
USA put the doctors back up so I can
thank them all we'll continue to lean on
your expertise our medical a-team and
dr. Compton Phillips from Washington
State thanks for being with us today all
right your knowledge a programming note
for all of you we are witnessing history
in real time as kovat 19 continues to
spread taking a look back at historical
flus flu pandemics four lessons about
how to contain the spread of corona
virus will feature health experts
insights on those major outbreaks
starting with the Spanish flu from 1918
five flus available now you can watch by
logging on to Fox nation calm I'll be
hosting that it was my honor to serve
you there and here every day on
outnumbered overtime